is there a difference between setting
goals and achieving goals why is it that
so many people set goals they have goals
they have dreams they have aspirations
hopes and yet they don't achieve the
goals dreams hopes aspirations that they
have is it possible that there's a
disconnect between the intention
Desiring goal wanting or goal setting
part of your brain and the goal
achieving part of your brain do you
think maybe the latest in Neuroscience
research and understanding which part of
our brain is responsible for setting a
goal and getting charged up and
emotionally connected to that goal fires
up and then what happens along the way
and let me share with you some things
that I've discovered that I think will
help you become a goal achiever instead
of a goal Setter and all the research
that I've done on the brain and Peak
Performance High performers people who
achieve their goals and people who have
goals there's a couple things that I
think you need to know need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation Hey
Kevin Michael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best John Assaraf and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
number one setting goals is great and
you're using you know what I call is the
Einstein part of your brain right the
part of your brain where you can imagine
and Einstein said imagination is more
important than knowledge
maybe at first and skill but you also
use a part of your brain called the
deductive reasoning part of your brain
where you say well I don't want that I
want that I don't like this I like that
and therefore here's really what I want
to do be have achieve Etc
and so we have the imagination we have
the deductive reasoning part of the
brain and if you thought of your brain
as a organism instead of an organ it's
an organism that is consistently you
know growing developing creating new
distinctions new awarenesses new neural
connections new patterns reinforcing old
patterns but if you thought of your
brain as a series of members of your
Orchestra or your band and there's one
member of your band or orchestra that
can choose what song to play but there's
another member of your band that decides
whether to play it or not or whether
it's not perfect or whether you should
go fast or slow but if you start to
think about one part of your brain
chooses the goal but you have to engage
the other members of the orchestra or
the band to help play and make Harmony
and um and coherence so if you choose
your goal that's great get clear get
precise so your brain knows exactly what
to focus on but the other part that you
really want to activate I'm going to
give you two more parts specific ones
the first part is the emotional part of
your brain the limbic part of your brain
so what happens is we set a goal we get
motivated you know to achieve it because
it's exciting it's fun we can foresee
what it would be like to achieve the
goal how people will think of us how we
will feel about it what it means to our
lifestyle our family our friends our
Charities Etc but if we don't know how
to override any of the obstacles that
will get in the way a
we're not going to achieve our goals so
let me explain a little bit deeper what
I mean by that in most cases setting of
the intention or the goal is happening
in the left prefrontal cortex and
Imagination centers I mentioned but
whenever we have a fear for example a
failing or a fear of disappointing
ourselves or a fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged in case we
don't achieve the goal
then the emotional center of our brain
the limbic system
deactivates motivational centers and
deactivates the desire to take inspired
action so we procrastinate and we
self-sabotage so if one part of the band
or orchestra wants to go this way but
another part of the band is trying to
protect ourselves
from any of the disempowering emotions
or outcomes that may happen we may fail
we may lose money we may get in trouble
of some kind
then we're going to have one part of the
band One to go this way but another pan
part of the band wants to stay where
it's comfortable and safe in our comfort
zone so how do we create the coherence
between
the Desiring goal setting part of the
brain
and this emotional Center that's holding
us back or moving us forward the
emotional centers right and there's one
more piece after that so stay tuned so
the first thing to know is that in
addition to setting a goal I want you to
do this little thing
I want you to take a piece of paper or
on your computer or on your mobile phone
and I want you to write out five reasons
why you must achieve that goal not could
should want to know why must you achieve
that goal and I want you to come up with
the biggest musts that you can rule
number two focus on positivity crazy
time in the world right now so much
uncertainty
unpredictability
chaos confusion
lots of stuff that's happening right now
that
none of us have ever been a part of
stuff like it yeah World War II
some recessions sure
but never anything like this with so
many different competing threats
so many different competing things to be
thinking about that affect your life
every day your business your career your
family your health lots of stuff going
on and the question I want you to be in
what are you going to do to make sure
that your health is better than it is
right now and that your finances are
better than they are right now that your
relationship is better than it is right
now that your career or business is
better than it is right now
and the reason I want you to focus on
making it better is because where your
attention goes energy flows let me
repeat where your attention goes energy
flows so if your attention is on oh my
God what's happening what am I going to
do about it what if this happens what if
that happens what if I can't what if I
don't what if I
listen what if you do
what if you focus your energy and
attention on how to make everything
better right now what will you do
differently today tomorrow this week
next week what will you do differently
is what's going to make the difference
more of the same equals
more of the same so I want you to
recalibrate your focus recalibrate your
attention recalibrate your intention and
then I want you to start some planning
Behavior equals results and it's the
behavior you take or the behavior you
don't take either one is a behavior
you have more control than you think you
do
you have more abilities than you think
you do
and I know that with focused attention
and follow through right follow through
you can have a great next 90 days the
question is are you committed to a great
next 90 days I am looking for me my team
my private clients you to finish the
year off strong
and to start next year fast
and strong and that's going to take some
thinking some planning and execution the
discipline to follow through to
completion are you in for the challenge
I'm here to support you my team's here
to support you the tribe is here to
support you together we're going to lift
each other as we climb towards having an
amazing next few months rule number
three have a clear mindset is it
possible to have a really great mindset
yet it's still not achieve your goals
and dreams I think you know the answer
is absolutely there are so many people
that are happy they are positive they're
always the bubbly light in the room and
yet many people with a great attitude
and a mindset don't achieve their goals
and dreams and have you ever considered
why have you ever considered that having
a great attitude and being happy and
being probably and always being positive
may be a part of the formula for success
but not the entire
formula for Success when I was learning
how to achieve goals not set goals
achieve goals I learned
three things that were required in order
to make my goals a reality and it
doesn't matter if you have you know
goals for uh spiritual connectivity and
well-being whether it's emotional
stability and balance whether it's
mental focus and awareness or whether
it's physical health and well-being
mindset is what separates the rest from
the best or the best from the rest any
way that you want to look at it but what
is mindset and maybe mindsets more than
attitude I think it is
so I look at mindset as the ability to
lock in on a goal to develop the skills
required to achieve that goal the
ability to overcome obstacles that come
in your way to achieve that goal
and to develop and Implement a plan
that's going to give you predictability
for achieving the goal versus a
possibility for achieving that goal so
what if part of your mindset was to
think about the goal that you want okay
and have the attitude that I'm going to
achieve it no matter what and whatever
comes into my way I'm going to do
whatever it takes I'm going to be
persistent I'm going to be an
adaptationist I'm going to go left go
right go up go down go around I'm going
to do everything possible to achieve
that goal but then the other part is how
specifically am I going to achieve that
goal like what are the strategies and
the tactics meaning what are you going
to do how specifically are you going to
do it by when
right so now when we have you know an
attitude of goal achievement of getting
clear on the goal coming up with what
I'm going to do on Monday at nine
o'clock and here's how I'm gonna do it
and here's whose help I need I'm going
to put it right into my calendar and I'm
going to take inspired action and when
an obstacle comes in my way I'm going to
ask myself empowering questions like
how can I overcome this obstacle what
can I do to overcome this obstacle whose
help do I need what book can I read what
do I need to search on Google what
YouTube video can I watch to overcome
this obstacle where can I learn better
strategies and tactics to make what I do
more efficient more productive more
constructive versus me just working hard
and long trying to do what to do there's
a formula called PPP equals PPP and it
goes like this piss poor planning equals
piss-poor performance and many people I
have found don't have any real plans for
what they're going to do today this week
this month this quarter they show up
every morning okay without a road map to
go from where they are to where they
want to be by the end of the day
so what are you going to do today
to achieve your health goals your wealth
goals your relationship goals your
career goals your business goals your
fun goals the experiences you want your
charitable goals what are you going to
do today or this week to move yourself
forward to make progress every single
day then what are you going to do to
manage your mindset and your emotions
what are you going to do to overcome the
obstacles that are in your area whether
they're mental obstacles physical
obstacles Financial obstacles
strategical obstacles tactical obstacles
now you may be watching me right now
going oh my God there's so much stuff
there well yeah if you want to achieve
goals
there's a thinking there is a feeling
and there's a behavior that gets you
there and there's also a thinking a
feeling in a behavior that does not get
you there most people you know confuse
activity with productivity they confuse
setting goals from achieving goals they
don't understand that you have to create
some kind of a road map to reduce the
resistance and uncertainty and stress
and fear and anxiety in your brain so
that you activate your motivational
centers
a motive for Action Center in your brain
so that you actually take action instead
of repeating your old patterns over and
over again achieving goals is a science
setting goals is an exercise in
imagination and hope and prayer of what
you would like so
mindset how you approach it what you do
how you overcome obstacles when you
focus on how you will because you must
you start to achieve goals the mindset
of a winner
is one of Relentless Pursuit until I
achieve the goal rule number four seek
new experiences consistently it dawned
on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness is especially pay close
attention especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they're comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you can
thinking or feeling
not today tomorrow
that's the language okay that the brain
uses the rationalizations the rational
lies that your brain my brain
everybody's brain uses to keep you in
your comfort zone well guess what
everything you want financially in your
relationship health-wise is just outside
your comfort zone if you keep
challenging and expanding your mental
emotional physical spiritual Financial
Comfort zones you expand as a human
being and you start fulfilling more of
your potential than standing on the edge
of it hoping and praying and wishing
that you can have greater better results
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key to takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five take
risks in our brain we're always
balancing out whether to move forward or
to retreat into safety and so the reason
we don't take action and we
procrastinate and sabotage in a lot of
cases because our brain is processed
that taking action is riskier than
remaining the same and here is something
that your brain's always doing
it is analyzing okay your stories
reasons excuses and potential
uncomfortable feelings or outcomes
against the behavior that needs to be
taken and so it's easier for us to
remain the same than it is for us to
overcome our fears it's easier for us to
remain the same versus overcome our
limiting beliefs it's easier for us to
remain the same versus challenging our
self-esteem self-worth stories and
excuses so when you have a big must why
you must achieve that goal and when that
must is bigger than your self-image your
stories your excuses or your fears that
is when you will take action so you have
to create leverage with your big must
or musts and so when you have your five
big musts and you compare them against
remaining the same or the fear of
failure or the fear being embarrassed of
Shame ridiculed or judged when your must
is bigger than those things that's when
you'll take inspired action and you
already know this if you followed my
work that we do more to avoid pain
or discomfort whether it's real or
imagined we do more to avoid pain or
discomfort real or imagined than we will
do to gain pleasure so we have to create
leverage in our mind rule number six
reframe negative experiences a lot of
people ask me what happens in our brain
when we have a traumatic experience or a
negative experience or an experience
where we're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or judged whether it's as a
kid or as an adult
well as you know the neurons that fire
together wire together right and what
happens when we have a negative
experience or a painful one
is that those neurons that wire together
create this memory in the amygdala the
emotional reactive center of the brain
and that amygdala is tied deeply towards
survival and avoidance of any pain or
discomfort so it is one of the most
refined parts of our brain the amygdala
the emotional responsent of our brain
when we have a pleasurable experience
that gets more wired in the hippocampus
part of our brain and so why do we avoid
things that might cause us pain or
discomfort uh well that's just the way
we're wired and we will move further and
further and further away from something
and faster away from something then we
will move towards gaining the pleasure
it's just the way the circuitry is
working and so what we need to
understand is the circuits work
perfectly and that means that your brain
works perfectly now the key is to become
better at recognizing
and managing emotions and for that we
have the for our process right recognize
thoughts emotions feelings Sensations
behaviors
when you have an emotion
or a feeling that doesn't feel
comfortable
breathe 60 breaths you know that inner
size take six calm the circuits well you
inner size breathe your way through it
and then to do inner size number two
which is Aya awareness of the thoughts
feelings emotions Sensations and
behaviors and it's in the awareness that
you have choice and it's in the choice
that you have freedom
when you make the choices to take action
anyway and to be aware of the old
pattern and to disempower it disengage
it don't reinforce it right if we keep
reinforcing these disempowering patterns
then guess what we do
we keep doing them over and over and
over and over again so recognize
reframe them by giving them a different
meaning
release them through breathing and
retrain your brain by taking inspired
action anyway
so
there's nothing wrong with your emotions
nothing wrong with your feelings some
are empowering you some are
disempowering you some are positive some
are negative some are constructive some
are destructive
I have emotions I'm not my emotions I
have feelings I'm not my feelings
I have a brain I am not my brain
I can use my brain better
awareness is what's going to give you
choice and choice is what ultimately
will give you the freedom that you want
rule number seven stop sabotaging
yourself have you ever considered that
procrastination is a behavior
when you choose either
by your own decision making or because
of automatic decision making patterns
not to take action on either a goal that
you have a business achievement you want
to create writing a book or anything
that you have the goal or Vision or
dream to achieve
when you don't take action and you're
procrastinating that in itself is a
behavior right in essence it's a form of
self-sabotage where you have a vision
you have a goal you want it but you
still don't take action on it or you
take a little bit of action and then you
stop
the question is why why do we
procrastinate why do we self-sabotage
and the answer must be something in your
brain right and the obvious solution is
to find out well what's triggering
procrastination what's triggering the
self-sabotaging behavior
and usually it's going to come down to
one of three things all right number one
is fear fear of not doing it well enough
fear of being judged fear of being
embarrassed the work that you've done
fear of failing
those are you know just a few of the
fears that may be holding you back the
other thing that it could be is that the
achievement of the goal that you have
the thing that you want maybe just
outside of your hidden self-image and so
when your hidden self-image sees that
the thing that you want is bigger than
your current comfort zone your current
Comfort is all based on your hidden
self-image then you're going to
procrastinate and self-sabotage these
are just automatic circuits and
mechanisms in your brain
and then there's you know the third one
that everybody knows about that's
limiting beliefs is we could have
limited beliefs that you know we're not
smart enough we don't have the skill
we're too young or too old and so any
one of those three things limiting
beliefs fears or self-image challenges
that are hidden in the subconscious mind
is really what you have to go to work at
to change those when you change those
you're in essence removing the obstacles
that are impeding you from actually
taking inspired action rule number eight
choose positive habits habits there's
another part of your brain called the
striatum
which is connected or part of a network
known as your hippocampus a part of your
brain called your hippocampus where your
memories and habits are interrelated
between hippocampus and striatum now
habits are created in our brain to
conserve energy to not have us think
consciously about what we need to do so
here is my question for you what is one
habit
that by starting this habit makes the
achievement of that goal
predictable
so is it waking up early and upgrading
your skills by 20 minutes is it going to
bed early is it being in a coaching
program or a mastermind program we have
accountability is it you know doing 15
minutes of exercise a day is it stopping
to eat certain foods is it you know
having a meeting with your significant
other every week to talk about your
goals and how you're feeling what is a
keystone habit I call it
that's going to move you forward that
over the next 100 days not 20 days 10
days 5 days or 33 days 100 days when you
develop that habit that habit then
develops you meaning a positive
constructive empowering habit that you
focus on for a short period of time
every day that moves you towards that
goal there are behaviors that when you
apply them every single day like a
ritual a habit they are the building
blocks to achieve any goal and since we
know that every single goal that you
want to achieve in health wealth
relationships career business finance is
fun experiences charities
all the how to exists but you have to
have the habits to not just create a
pattern that is short-term but a pattern
that is long-term now initially you have
to use conscious effort energy and
attention to create a habit but you can
deliberately and consciously choose
habits versus being a victim of the
habits rule number nine practice
self-awareness you may have heard me say
before awareness is what gives you
choice
and choice is what can give you Freedom
right so awareness of what
awareness of your thoughts what are you
thinking about most of the time is it
constructive is it destructive
are your thoughts empowering you or
disempowering you are they positive or
negative now what if you were able to
practice being aware
without judgment
blame shame guilt or justification let
me repeat no judgment blame shame guilt
or justification now why do you want to
get good at awareness
the answer is because awareness
is what allows you to see patterns
and once you see a pattern
then you can change the pattern in all
of the research that's been done around
addictions for example whether it's
addictions to nicotine sex porn
sugar
overeating under eating over exercising
not exercising one of the key things
that all the scientists agree on now is
the very Act of observing and learning
your patterns allows you to determine
whether you want that pattern to
continue
and to also ask why is this pattern here
what's causing the things that I do
what is causing these thoughts what's
triggering these emotions what's behind
the anger what's behind the fear what's
behind
the feeling like I'm not good enough
worthy enough
Etc and in that quiet observation
without judgment blame shame guilt or
justification we can start to make
modifications
and then we use our higher cortical
functions of intention
attention and action to change so
awareness intention attention and action
that is the simple version of how we
change how we become more how we
surrender allow accept
all of us have patterns some serve us
well some don't that's just a natural
fact most of it's because of childhood
experiences the meaning that we gave
things the skills that we gained or
didn't gain
so what the key is start right now get
better today get better tomorrow get
better the next day over the course of
three months six months 12 months
you have more mental control you have
more emotional control you have more
Direction on your behaviors
and when you learn what you should be
doing
holy mackerel you could be healthier
happier wealthier and more and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is celebrate all of
your successes I was just thinking that
a lot of us are
you know consistently focusing on our
goals what do we want to achieve
what do we want to let go of who do we
want to become where do we want to go
who do we want to help
a lot of goals right what about
celebrations
have you considered that part of the
goal achieving process and part of how
you activate the reward center of your
brain is you focus also on what is it
that you've achieved up until now what
hurdles have you overcome up until now
whenever we think about challenges that
we've faced that we've overcome whenever
we think about the lessons we've learned
from those challenges whenever we think
of anything as simple as learning how to
ride a bike as a kid and learning how to
speak the languages that we speak and
learning how to do math and learning how
to cook and learning how to get dressed
and learning learning learning and doing
doing and accomplishing accomplishing
accomplishing any time we think of those
things
we're activating that same neural
network
and that Reward Center which actually
increases motivation so when we remind
ourselves of all the things that we have
done and accomplished and overcome
we fuel the future things that we must
overcome and the future things that we
want to accomplish so today
for this beautiful weekend is um you
know gone why not write a list of all
the things that you can think of
that you have overcome and you've
achieved and celebrate celebrate
celebrate celebrate
when you start talking about my brain
it's an organ it's like your heart is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can you
know speed up the brain waves in your
brain you can slow them down you can
tune in you can tune out yeah we haven't
been given the user's manual for the
most powerful we're aware of that's
right and so the great news you know I
know you being an athlete in a
successful businessman you have
discipline you cannot
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and Jim Rohn is I know you
you love Jim Royce so you either pay the
price of discipline or you pay the price
of regret discipline weighs ounces
regret weighs tons but the thing is can
you teach discipline the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant and if the participants
reason why
is big enough if they know I want to
achieve X and the reason why the motive
for their action motivation the motive
for their action
is a reason Beyond just themselves
chances are they will do more
yeah to achieve that success than if it
was just left up to their own but there
are some people that are born you know
with Incredible Drive they just have
this insatiable drive and they'll just
I'll do whatever it takes
for the things that I want and there's
other people that want things but they
just don't have this insatiable drive
and this is where you know I as much as
I hated school I love to use schools and
analogy yeah in The Game of Life whether
it's health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level the game
do I want to play at is it the great
school level the kindergarten level the
high school level the university level
the pro level because each one of those
levels requires a totally different
mindset and totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a pro business person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude and the talent now
we're talking about there's some real
potential here and what we don't know is
you know what's in your heart like what
is the fire that stirs you that that you
wake up saying I will do this even when
I don't feel like it I will do whatever
it takes to overcome my Temptation for
mediocracy my Temptation for excuses my
Temptation for
um reasons and circumstances to hold me
back I won't allow those to be in my way
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose right and so
the question you asked before is how do
you develop that start small yeah start
small
so if you don't have discipline show to
your show yourself that you can give
yourself one command and one follow
through so you know what
um right now I'm going to get up I'm
going to do two push-ups right now not
not like later now can you give yourself
a simple command one sit up right now
I'm gonna go get a glass of water you
start with something ridiculous I
learned many years ago reduce it to the
ridiculous so for reducer to the
Ridiculousness I start I said can you do
that great will you
because that's the difference right
there is that's the razor's Edge the
people who can will you will you yeah
great when now now yeah right so if you
develop that skill and specifically from
a brain plasticity a neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that you
give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern that you can
give yourself a command and take action
now that maybe just be one time
well what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you're if my
computer was open I'd have um every hour
it would say it's 12 o'clock it's one
o'clock and I take 60 Seconds
just to be in control of my mind 66 I
don't care where I'm not what you're
doing stop takes six breaths just get it
just gets centered am I on track am I
off track am I doing something I
shouldn't be doing versus a high impact
activity that I need to be doing every
hour I've trained myself to just reset
I didn't always do that so I just
started with
One A Day right then two sure then three
then it was working so well I said great
let's do this every hour if we have
constructive positive empowering beliefs
we move forward and take action but when
we have a limiting belief like I'm not
good enough I'm not smart enough I'm not
worthy I'm not skilled I'm too young I'm
too old I'm too white I'm too black them
to Asian Caucasian I'm this or I'm that
I'm not enough of this I'm not enough of
that
where are our beliefs
right we have two types of beliefs we
have conscious beliefs that we can
declare and then we have subconscious
beliefs as well which ones are the more
powerful of the two Mike Edwards says
subconscious beliefs
right Mike
says subconscious beliefs were you born
with any beliefs like if you were a
neural anatomist
okay if you're a neuroanatomist if you
were to look in the brain where would
you find your beliefs the positive the
negative ones the good ones the
challenging ones the construct of
Destruction where would you find them
what are they like what are they
right like what are they
aren't those patterns that have been
reinforced based on what we learned in
childhood aren't those patterns that our
parents gave us our teachers our
brothers our sisters our neighbors
right didn't we
develop our beliefs
through the imprinting year zero to five
or six the modeling years five or six to
you know seven or eight and then the um
the um
um experiential years right all the way
from birth to 25 26 when our brain was
pretty plastic and we developed these
beliefs about what to believe we weren't
born with any they're nothing more than
neural patterns in the brain now how
many of you have heard the word
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity right what is
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity is the
scientific fact that our brain is
plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain it means that we
have brain cells right so the brain
cells okay there's a cell there's an
axon okay or a body then there's
dendrites at the end right and there's
synapse gaps in between the brain cells
so those brains have potentiality and
let's say we are told that you're not
good enough you're not smart enough
you're not worthy you'll never amount to
much you're too young you're too old you
don't have enough knowledge you don't
have enough skill if those patterns are
created and those neurons are active and
releasing those neural chemicals from a
receptor or from a um ascending neuron
to a receptor neuron and that happens
often enough that neuron structure or
pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the pathways that are active and
reinforcement We Are Young become the
default Pathways just like the highways
and the roads that you take every single
day to go to the stores you take now if
it's true that our neural pathways are
not fixed but the pathways that are easy
to run across okay or to fire the
signals okay are the ones that are
dominant is it possible to let go of the
limiting destructive disempowering
beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural Pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right so if a neural pathway can be
created and neural Pathways can be
deactivated
then why not deliberately and
consciously evolve yourself someone's
listening right now and they're thinking
you know there's a lot of things I want
you know I want to get out of this
relationship or I want the relationship
I want to have a better health I want to
have more money which may be and they've
been saying that for years and they feel
like they've been consuming all the
information they need to have but they
haven't been able to take action maybe
because their why isn't powerful enough
what would you say should be their first
step well the first step is to take one
thing I'm going to go back to one thing
yeah and say great let me move one thing
forward why because that just changes
the trajectory of the same pattern
repeating itself and as soon as you
interrupt a pattern and then you
repeatedly interrupt the pattern it's
like taking a detour
and as soon as you take a detour one day
you're like okay that was that was okay
but you intended your Tendencies don't
want to go back to what's comfortable
but if you take the detour two days Six
Days Seven Days we know from a
neuroscience perspective it takes about
66 days to create a solid enough neural
pattern that it'll go from conscious
effort and thinking about it to a
non-conscious pattern that has the
beginnings of automaticity happening
without your involvement you're just
doing it yeah and so for me what I do
and for myself
is I uh whenever I want to change
something whether it's a habit whether
it's a thought or emotion or behavior I
say I'm going to work on this for 100
days not 30 days not 21 days not 66
which is right around there I say 100
days
and then I focus all of my just on that
one thing for 100 days why to give an
example of something you've done Sugar
Sugar I'm a sugar me too I'm a sugar
like if it was an alcoholic I'm a sugar
a hole right it's so bad so you take one
thing just one thing that you know maybe
a little challenging 100 days 100 days
just 100 days so let's say you want to
drink more water 100 days a glass a day
conscious effort to want to do whatever
you did before you'll still do but one
glass a day so you know I started that
with my assistance I want to drink you
know like four of these a day you know
like you know 32 ounces whatever the
case is and so every we got a mug and
it's on my desk every time I walk in and
then I have some support from her saying
hey remember to drink your water so just
do it so the first you know two three
weeks I feel like I'm gonna drown myself
with so much water
um but then it's like okay now I'm used
to it now I'm drinking as much water as
possible because the Habit is there and
one of the rules that I love to follow
is the Habit is more important than the
intensity at first
so don't worry about the intensity right
develop the habit
so can you take one minute a day to
focus on how you will achieve a goal
just one minute a day can you take one
minute a day to focus on your health
you take one day to retrain your brain
yeah can I take one day
you know or one action a day right and
you start off with something you know
and reduce it down to just a minute or
two minutes or one Behavior if you can
get that behavior to be a habit it's
easy to stack right of course it's just
like the foundation of a building once
you have the foundation if you build it
right you stack and so every good
discipline affects another and every bad
discipline affects others until you
learn how to master your mindset by
recognizing what's holding you back the
real reasons that you're not taking the
actions that you need to take and learn
how to reframe them in the right part of
your brain so you can override the
messaging signal from the amygdala the
fear Center the emotional center of the
brain to the part of the brain that's
responsible for taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties for your success fear failure
fear losing your job fear of losing your
home fear losing your money
you have to understand that just like a
car has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not and
if you're lacking the confidence and the
certainty it's going to cause doubt if
you're going to have doubt it may cause
anxiety and as soon as that sets in the
brain in a nanosecond your ability to
take action is like having one foot on
the gas and one foot on the brake
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on the tires but you're really not going
to get anywhere
so the first thing I want you to do is
write down what's really holding you
back why aren't you really get clear get
deep why aren't you really taking action
towards any of your goals health goals
financial goals business goals whatever
goals you have
write that down and ask yourself
is this real is this imagined is it a
probability or is it a possibility what
you'll find for the most part is the
negative consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility you're going to do
everything possible to run away to fight
Freeze or fight that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back
to reframing the possibility to to for
the probability to just a normal
possibility
you start to activate different parts of
your brain that start showing you the
solutions to how to overcome the fear
how to overcome the risk how to overcome
the possible negative consequence and
then what happens is the amygdala the
part of your brain that's responsible to
protect you and keep you safe the firing
threshold of that signal gets lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start take action and
third what is happening is that your
left prefrontal cortex the CEO the
genius part of your brain starts to
think about ways that you can actually
take action and do it faster and easier
and better it starts to change what you
see start to change your vibration and
now you start to have a lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action what if you said
Okay I want to make let's just say a
hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million it doesn't make a difference and
I asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve this so I need to believe I'm
smart enough good write down I am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
I need to believe that I am worthy I
need to believe that I deserve this I
need to believe that it's possible I
need to really you write down five or
six or seven beliefs they're just words
on a sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment I'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this I want you to imagine that somebody
tapped you on the shoulder sometime
today and say hey
um I work with Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks in Hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks now I
want you to imagine you've never seen
the script you don't know how to act but
they said to you we're going to give you
an acting coach we're going to give you
everything you need to memorize the
script we're going to do everything you
need to act it perfectly what would you
do to take that script that's on a piece
of paper that you've never seen before
what would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once uh would you read it maybe a
hundred times 200 times 500 times you
think you might role play with somebody
while you're holding the script in your
hand do you think you might research the
rule do you think you might take a
camera and practice it and do you think
that if you practice it one time 50
times 100 times 500 times you can
finally put the script down and you can
get in front of the camera and go boom
here is the script do you think you
could do that well guess what a script
that's on a piece of paper that you
don't believe with practice you start to
believe so what happens if you take a
belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain they've been reinforced and when
you learn how to deactivate the
destructive ones and activate
constructive ones through space
repetition and reinforcement now you are
resetting your default way of being so a
belief is nothing more than a reinforced
pattern that if you learn how to
deactivate it and create a new one it's
like a software upgrade for your brain
when I analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back
over there on my on my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
uh you need to learn how to manage you
need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats that you have to
wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do
you'd have to find how do I get somebody
who could do the surgery so for those of
you who are not good at marketing or
sales which is the oxygen required for
any business regardless of how good your
product or service are the question you
want to be asking yourself is this who
can I hire to help me or who can I
barter with to help me who can I partner
with to help me do my marketing and
sales if you're not good at that so
higher partner barter or defer payment
to get it done because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done at the end of your
day or week do you ever find yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation and your financial
future may never seem to be improving
you might be finding yourself living
paycheck to paycheck right now with not
a lot of breathing room and I would
imagine no discretionary income or even
time team to spend on the little things
that really would make your life more
enjoyable well what I can share with you
is you're not alone that's number one
and in most cases the real problem is
not your current circumstances what the
real problem is that most people repeat
the same
patterns of thought and behaviors over
and over again and that is the cause of
what more of the same results but they
are looking for different results and so
today I'm going to show you how to break
that pattern break that cycle now you
see when you think of your results your
results are effects and so the question
is effects of what and the answer is
your results are all effects of what you
believe to be true about yourself what
you believe to be true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now if you think about what
you believe and if you think about your
habits that is what is causing the
effect that you may not like right now
and so a simple logical thing to do
would be to understand that if I could
change my beliefs about what was
possible and what was possible for me
specifically and I could create more
empowering habits than my result will
change and what I love to focus on
having done an enormous amount of brain
research over the last 10 years is
something called your inner game and
your inner game is comprised of
obviously your beliefs your attitude
your perceptions how you see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action and so
let me share just a little story with
you that may help you understand what I
mean
about two years ago I was at a seminar
and when I got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and I could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and I saw tears
streaming down her eyes and when she got
through the crowd for a moment I thought
that maybe there was something wrong but
she actually had tears of joy in her
eyes and when I met her her name was
Joni Sanderson and this was in Perth
Australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and I go well for what
she says well
about a year ago I heard you speak about
beliefs and habits and mastering my
emotions and really working on my
self-worth and she said to me that she
was a caregiver and that she loved
helping families who needed extra
assistance for their aging parents or
for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a Widow's pension of about twelve
thousand Aussie dollars a year and so
she really didn't have enough money to
be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so I shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said I don't know
and when I shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth and she said to me I think I'm
worth more I said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level of your brain you have
this feeling that maybe you're not smart
enough or not good enough or not worthy
enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior and so what I helped Joni do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was I helped her recognize
that beliefs Drive Behavior beliefs
Drive emotions habits Drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future even your
presence circumstances right now why not
focus on working on the neural patterns
the beliefs and habits that are nothing
more than patterns in the brain that
drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and so
she started to work on what I call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and More in empowered and what I
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widows from
a Widow's pension and living paycheck to
paycheck to being able to charge for her
services and she was making 75
000 a year
because you made a this far new video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my last one-on-one with the
amazing John ass rap check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there we all own the most powerful
bio computer in the world in the
universe
and most people don't know how to change
their brain to change their income